colonoscopy all right you got to do that
when you're 40 right
well it depends on what you got oh [__]
all right well I got AIDS uh I don't
know what to do all right I got a pretty
wide [__] I think I'll be all right
with the camera I mean you could get a
full
I gotta do kegels all right
I can do that I got a really strong
[__] like if I have a turd that I
can't get out I can cigar snip it with
my [__] pretty impressive
oh yeah
yeah I could circumcise a kid with my
[__] pretty sure
oh yeah not saying I want a kid's a dick
in my ass I'm just saying if I had to do
it I could do it
old tight [__] Norman over here
that's what they used to call me in
college
yes sir I told an abortion joke recently
and a woman approached me she was like
hey that's very insensitive I've had an
abortion you shouldn't tell jokes like
that I was like whoa hey sorry I just
told a joke I think what you did was
much worse
we hate to admit it we've come a long
way like in the 50s we had whites only
and blacks only water fountain which is
incredibly sad especially if you're a
thirsty Asian
so quiet so secure Asians every other
group's got a brag and boast every
group's got a slogan black people I'm
Black and I'm Proud white people white
power Hispanics
not an Asian ninjas head down grades up
that's it
that's a bet you never hear about Asian
crime never if I was an Asian guy I
would just start mugging people like hey
it's my word against yours
boy I hate flying that's the worst part
about this gig I hate flying I like a
train give me an Amtrak any day I love a
train trains have such low self-esteem
you know no bag check no security it's
almost like they want a terrorist
I love it I hate flying flying is so
high maintenance flying's like a high
maintenance chick like you want to get
inside me you gotta here an hour early
take your shoes off and do a body scan
you're like Jesus Christ
come on trains like a fat chick like get
a beer get in here
racism it's alive and well man I was
just down in Knoxville Tennessee you
guys ever been there
what a [__] holy hell they are 30
years behind over there you ever go to a
town so small they're still racist
towards certain white people you know
they're like hey watch out over there
that's what the dirty Irish live I was
like Jesus Christ
wow you guys haven't made it to black
people yet
and again these are all jokes take it
easy I uh I'm not racist I look at
racism the same way I look at Nickelback
yeah
yeah you know it's uh it's fun to joke
about but uh you never want to see it
live
yeah and you're like
yeah dude black girls yeah what that's
what you don't know this no I'm not on
the uh Black People Meet no dude it's on
Tinder do you ever date like a like a
black nerd no never I I've never dated a
uh a black I'm a person I've been with
you but I never dated really yeah
personal choice or is that like
circumstance is that like hard line I
just I just never I don't want to date
anybody but they never pursued so if the
girl's like we have to date now I'm like
all right we gotta hear you saying yeah
yeah but a black chick was never like
hey call me exactly I never got you
never got called yeah yeah but I've
banged a few and that was great and
terrifying but uh never uh never dated
what would you talk about Cosby he's
married to a black lady what is that
second black wedding second black yeah
marriage
I'm trying to add the extra word every
time Norman says yeah baby tell me
everything I do that like whenever I see
women I like I shudder like sometimes I
just look at them like what the [__] I'm
like how powerful I'm sorry man you guys
just kick so much but didn't you have
that experience when shooting gave birth
though you watch your wife
that's the one thing that guys usually
switch over and they're like they are
strong this that was insane well it was
like I was crying you saw it well I was
I was on the other end because it was
like the oh the face and yeah the baby
had the umbilical cord around her neck
so they had to do the old oh yeah yeah
they had it three times I had it
sorry I had three I had it too comedy
podcast
are you married no single Virgin of
course yeah I can't imagine I bet you'd
be great in bed you're ripped I had the
best hairline in podcasts yeah I don't
know I haven't tried yet so we'll have
to see all right well let me know pretty
big hog on you
yeah I could see you pecking a crazy
crazy tool downtown
That Matters To Girls apparently yeah
that's all I hear about
that Alex is tricky I read an article
recently it said Alexa actually listens
everything you say stores it in a
database could use it against you later
I was like damn just like a real woman
now I'm all nervous like hey Alexa
what's the weather out there she's like
why don't you ask Siri oh boy
yeah it's got to be hard to be a kid now
I feel bad for kids so much stimulus
coming to kids iPhone internet social
media remember I have to go look at
where's kids not a care in the world
maybe running the car shotgun
that was like the biggest problem in my
life shotgun
yeah I never see kids doing that anymore
the only time a kid yells it out now is
in a classroom
[Music]
Magic Johnson's still living crazy he
beat Kobe he keeps
all right unlike him that joke landed
all right
thanks for having me we appreciate you
coming on dude it took too long oh hey
you got a big guy I mean I'm you're
slumming after Road you're number two
I'll take it not bad no fanny pack and
no n-word scandal
so welcome here into the in the studio
it's good to have you
yeah I'm a little hungover a little gay
but uh just glad to be
here with you sister well I appreciate
you saying that I'm very happy to be
here with you too all right all right
hiding my erection but uh yeah this is
great yeah yeah but my place I own a
piece of the Rock in Manhattan it's the
only thing my parents have been proud of
that I've done I've done The Tonight
Show Conan Colbert Comedy Central but
when I bought my apartment that's when
they actually started answering my phone
calls but hey that's why I'm a comedian
because uh I gotta get love somewhere
oops sorry is that a me too all right so
but for you being I mean you're young so
getting into this business
getting into this business and
um
35 35 not that young but uh you know not
on the Viagra yet
or am I
who knows
I like to snort it
I read a news article about obesity they
said they're thinking about putting
microchips in obese people's brains it
shocks them every time they think about
food
I was like if we have that kind of
technology I feel like we should be
using that on pedophiles
why are we wasting that on chubs
I don't care about your candy intake I'm
worried about your candy output
priorities people eat all the cupcakes
you want just don't touch Little Debbie
um the other day story about that
um resource officer who arrested the
six-year-old girl and the eight-year-old
boy he has officially been fired yeah of
course because he's dumb wait what
happened what'd he do so is this
six-year-old I don't know we're having a
temper tantrum he looks identical to
Cleveland he's a family guy he's just
not smart you got to get that guy out of
there he's gonna do something even more
stupid yep wait are we on we're on oh
geez all right I almost had a horrible
slur all right thank God I asked my
balls are so long I got them all ugly my
balls are brown and weird yeah why'd you
get that I think wear and tear I think
I've just beat it up and thrown it
around so much it's turned yeah it's
like elbow grease you know your elbow's
a little darker you know yeah and I
think it's just like that it's just
stretched and yanked and twisted well
yeah what you look like you're like
Turkish
I've gotten Cuban I I never have I'm too
scared but I'm I think part Sicilian
part French why are you scared I don't
want to get some black in me no I'm just
uh joking uh don't call the missus
I don't know then you gotta have kids oh
kids are scary I like babies babies are
fun you know why babies are great
because they're not evil yet there's a
million douchebags out there but you
never assume that baby will become one
isn't that nice that's why no one ever
goes up to a pregnant woman rubs her
belly and goes ooh this one's gonna suck
potential it's all positive oh it's
kicking might be a pro soccer player
it's never like oh it's kicking might
hit his wife
flew here from New York man I hate
flying you know they let you pick your
seat on a plane I think I'd rather pick
the person I'm sitting next to I don't
really give a [__] where I am on the
plane it's like a five hour relationship
make it more like a dating app
obese Nazi with a service dog swipe left
tiny Asian lady with a surgical mask
that's my gal
yes she is not a talker right but just
like a dating app she shows up with a
baby I'm like ah I got catfished
hand jobs are drinking drinking I hand
jobs I can get rid of in a second okay
you ever had a good one
uh well your ex was pretty good
uh I had a weird childhood how so well
let's see uh my dad got a wild hair up
his ass and bought a mansion dilapidated
Mansion a poor black neighborhood so
first of all the house was [__] we
barely had running water it was you know
we'd have family meetings all right go
[__] at school don't [__] here we need
the water and then my dad started
running out of money so he made the back
half of bed and breakfast like old style
but so my mom's whipping up pancakes at
8am and I'm like can I get one she's
like blow a big dick uh eat a bowl of
Cheerios you [__] and
check me out come see me
live before I kill myself